Heather just give us an overview on the
state of FD th deployment across the
Americas we are seeing tremendous growth
in the US over the Lynn last year in
2015 we saw the number of homes past
grow 12 / 12 percent 26 million homes
are now past so roughly twenty
twenty-five percent of our households
have access to fiber the home and then
the more interesting fact is that the
number of connections grew thirteen
percent so the take rate is really
increasing in fact our average take rate
in the US where fiber to the home is
available is up about is up to forty six
percent so if consumers have the option
they take it we're also seeing
tremendous growth in canada where the
incumbents are rolling out and it's up
to about seven hundred thousand homes
connected so a good good number what
we're seeing in the u.s. is people want
fiber to the home because they
understand the economic benefits over
the last couple years the council has
done two studies one on the impact of
gigabit access to communities and like
communities side by side communities
those that had access to gigabit had
about at one point four percent increase
in gdp over those who didn't comparable
communities and then last year we did a
study on real estate and for a home the
value increased about 3.1 percent if you
had fiber to the home and we did an
empirical study with a economist who
looked at all real estate transactions
really based on the data across the u.s.
and this supports our consumer research
that we do every year that has shown
that people will pay five about five
thousand dollars more to a fiber to the
home to purchase however if they've had
fiber to the home they'll pay six to
seven thousand dollars more
so what we say in the americas is fiber
is on fire well so are we talking really
about really that they almost consumer
demand is helping yes no one wants and
matt has been an interesting development
because consumers and communities now
understand that they have a
responsibility to help make the
investment case feasible so they will
work with their incumbents they will
work with a competitor or if they can't
get anyone else they will actually do it
themselves but kanuda T's understand now
which has been a change in the last 10
to 15 years that they have a role in
making investment in what has become an
essential infrastructure so how does the
work of the cams than your region help
to support this deployment we do a lot
of Education we work with communities we
work with network operators be they
incumbents competitor vote competitors
competitive over builders or even
municipalities we are ownership agnostic
we just want everyone to get fibre to
the home and we do a lot of education on
how they can make the investment case
more feasible and so we can get more
fiber the home driven out there
fantastic thank you very much for
speaking to us thank you so consumer
demand driving incredible growth right
across the Americas
you
you